Throughout the Asia Pacific region, most businesses are quite optimistic, going forward.
It's a very good reading.
When you break down this survey, it gets quite interesting...
...the Philippines was the most positive country with an index reading of 100.
Is business booming there?
Absolutely, I think that there is something happening in the Philippines,...
...it has been quite positive for the past few observations.
And I think that if you look at the data there is a good reason to think that...
...this is not just some crazy optimism,...
...indeed the Philippines has been growing at about five percent.
We expect it to grow again five percent this year.
The first quarter was amazing.
Inflation seems to be under control.
The peso is appreciating.
The stock market has been going up so we have about 13 percent return year-to-date...
...so I think this optimism is backed by solid economic data at least so far...
...and we might be up for a very positive surprise in the near future.